dozens paid their respects to the
American flag today 8 news now reporter
Joshua baguero takes us to Boulder City
for a flag disposal ceremony the
Daughters of the American Revolution has
been hosting for years
this largely ceremonial event instills
in Americans how to properly dispose of
an American flag a symbol that unites
all of us despite our many differences
old tattered in her color fading the
Star-Spangled Banner laid on the table
for Kurt Dunphy these flags have a deep
meaning we have a maybe that I think the
greatest country in the world
and yes we have some faults
but we're still a shining Beacon to a
whole lot of the world at least 30
American flags were retired at the
southern Nevada Veterans Memorial
Cemetery
these flags may have hung on someone's
front yard at a cemetery at a local
courthouse or School symbols of
America's founding and Independence when
an American flag is distressed it's it's
tattered it's sturdy it can't be flown
it's disrespectful
and so the flag must be retired
respectfully you you can't just throw it
in the garbage respectfully folks
carried the flags onto their last
journey step by step a black plume of
smoke bellowed into the air
this ceremony United gen Z with Baby
Boomers under the banner of the Red
White and Blue we're honoring not only
the country but ourselves and everything
that we stand for and so to be able to
honor all of that in just a couple of
seconds is absolutely amazing synthetic
Flags which are growing more popular
nowadays are disposing a more private
setting due to the dangerous chemicals
they emit reporting at the southern
Veterans Memorial Cemetery Joshua
progero eight news now